good morning John it's the day I go to
the Boost office didn't get my birth
Thanks
okay I put one of these it was so
amazing that I had to go and get the
camera while I open the rest of them
this is the first one that I opened I
think that's a Raymond's raving rabid
and it's got a corn dog with a candle in
it Thank You Adena this is so far my
favorite although I haven't opened the
rest of them yet I'm handsome awesome
and are tastic he's got lots of words in
it
Wow the fire dog are gonna make
nerdfighter bubble things it's big and
purple this one says I will do better in
real estate than in stocks which is good
because I have a house now says I will
frustrate my enemies by showing them
indifference which is generally how I
handle my enemies since I didn't realize
I had any this one is to jog someone was
confused about whose birthday lunch
that's a CD that's from a dump on two
different people
oh it's tight you put it to sent me an
email giraffes loving giraffes
this is not your birthday card where the
picture of this guy was obviously not
Tom happy birthday Hank nerdfighter
hands anybody know if you'll are I
realized that who could for a menace
risk by eating this despite not knowing
what it was but it is food in cinnamony
it's definitely candy do you yeah
acronym ESMA back to the post office it
turns out that I had a lot more mail but
I thought I did I had all these little
forms that said common to the post
office
we've got mail held for you because it
didn't know that nur ox and so I went in
and they gave me a lot more so I don't
think I'm gonna have time to talk about
all of them but here they are
that song if you are wondering was
summer song by Tom Milsom it will be on
his new album which will be out soon a
few superlatives that I must mention
individually this was definitely the
largest happy birthday card I've ever
received
possibly that anyone has ever received
this woman me not because there's
Katherine John and the Yeti who is
invisible in her coat this one made me
sad because apparently I could have gone
to Hogwarts if only it hadn't got stuck
in time somewhere this one made me
amazed because apparently this person
really wanted to see me in Grand Rapids
but was getting a bone-marrow transplant
so sorry you couldn't be there but I
loved your card and you were made of
Awesome not made of cancer this is from
Molly Lewis sweet Afton 23 and aside
from having some absolutely hilarious
commentary on these Elizabethan bunnies
with rainbows and unicorns
she was actually one of the only people
to give me an actual turtle but you
don't get what does it gift certificates
to keep it argh that's very exciting and
I really like this as well which is the
ABCs of dirt fighting and when you like
flip stuff up like see this bee you flip
it up and it's bumble the nerdfighting
puppy or if you go down to the G here
what's under G G is golden parachute so
thank you to Laura and Rachel for
putting this together I apologize if I
either missed or forgot about or haven't
received your card yet and I'm sure it
will continue to get an amazing birthday
stuff because nerdfighters are me too
awesome and you know how to make a man's
birthday absolutely freaking fantastic
John you will see me and my new green
screen tomorrow